it's like having an anchor you know
it's uh if i don't do it i feel like i'm
constantly
chasing the day meditation is the art of
awareness
awareness internally awareness
externally but also the
various millions of layers that exist in
the physical and the non-physical world
this is actually it's like a rocket it's
like a booster
because now everything around me is
happening in slow motion wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
reasons why you must start meditating
right now
reason number one it improves your
performance with kobe bryant
i meditate every day i meditate every
day and
i do it in the mornings and uh i do it
for about 10 to 15 minutes
and i think it's important because it
just it
it sets me up for the rest of the day
you know it helps me it's like it's like
it's like having an
anchor you know it's
if i don't do it i feel like i'm
constantly chasing the day
as opposed to being able to be
controlled and dictate today not that
you're
you know calling the shots on what comes
forward
but the fact that i am set and ready for
whatever may come my way
you know i have a calmness about
whatever comes my way and a poise
um and that comes from starting the
morning off with meditation
for me it's really just just listening
to to my inner self
i mean there's that's basically it like
you you
sit in silence and you just allow these
thoughts to come
forward and you get a chance to observe
um the self in in
in things that may be lying beneath the
surface that
if you don't have that time to sit
quietly on your own you'll never pay
attention to
you know because if you think about it
like you know the reality is we're
paying attention to so many things that
are going on around us
we're constantly taking selfies we're
constantly taking pictures to post on
instagram and all these other things
we're constantly observing everything
that's around us but
we don't take the time to really observe
what's going on inside of ourselves
and that's what meditation is for me in
2000 we had a new head coach that came
to the los angeles lakers by the name of
phil jackson
and phil was just coming off and winning
six championships with the bulls
and he was really big on mindfulness a
really big old meditation
and it wasn't an option for us so we'd
sit
in our film room and he'd turn the
lights out
and he would we would meditate as a
group
and he'd teach us mindfulness and it
really connected with me because he was
teaching
mindfulness through something that i was
extremely passionate about which was the
game of basketball
so it was told through the lens of this
is going to help you here
and so i had this curiosity about it
and um that was my introduction to
meditation
and then seeing the poise that we play
with the fact that we can be in a
hostile environment with fans yelling
and screaming
and you know pressure situations and it
in it having
no effect on us because we were never
too high never too low we were just in
the moment
and felt very secure in who we were
and that was my introduction to
meditation
i had a great experience which really i
learned a lot about meditation through
this experience i was
i was on a jet ski and i took the jet
ski out
in the ocean and i just kind of sat and
i just let the current just take me
wherever it was going to take me
and i really saw a lot of meditation
through that moment because i wasn't
trying to control
the moment i wasn't trying to force
myself upon the waves and dictate where
i was going to god just let the waves
take me there
and it was a lot of peacefulness
involved in that reason number two
it centers you with dave meltzer
meditation for me is 20 minutes every
morning
first thing that i do and what it does
is it finds my center
that's all that's all for me it's almost
like baseline testing for a concussion
because what i've learned is that life
is life is like
the big tall hill in san francisco with
a car on top
that's your center when the car is up
there you can hold it a you know a truck
you can hold with your finger when it's
sitting on top of a hill
the minute this thing starts rolling
downhill you got to put it back
up the longer it goes downhill the
harder it is to get back up
what i used to do during the day is i'd
let that truck keep flying down the hill
and trying to react instead of act by
going back to center
and is this emotional that's how i think
of it i think of it as anxiety stress
emotion those are the things i'm trying
to bring back to center correct
so anything that takes you off of peace
oneness wholeness that feel peaceful
feeling
if something moves me in that direction
instead of reacting
talking yelling all the different things
that throwing things whatever you are
go back to center hey this is dave
meltzer and i'm going to read my
favorite paragraph
of my friend evan carmichael's book
build to serve
here's the secret dream big
act small it is important to dream big
your big dreams will motivate you it'll
inspire you
to keep going when things get tough
it'll be a rallying call for your
partners suppliers
customers and future employees
keep a hold of your huge dream
and then act small
find the smallest possible way to get
started
to take the first step to get some
momentum going
dream big but act small reason number
three
it makes you more mindful with brendan
burchard you'll never
learn to observe your thoughts more and
be more mindful than when you just close
your eyes
focus on your breath hear your thoughts
but let them just come in and pass and
get to a point where you can
find a little bit of emptiness inside
create a little
white space inside so all the noise and
all the thoughts
aren't hitting you and impacting they're
just kind of
glancing and then at some point as you
meditate more and more and more
throughout your life
less and less thoughts pervade less and
less thoughts
when more thoughts bounce off and
suddenly you start to find an emptiness
and a space and from that emptiness in
space
as you get to experience that more you
get to use that more
in those moments where stimulus and
response are immediately happening
you start to find more space in there
because now you're more mindful of time
meditative practice opens up that space
between stimulus and response
and you develop that skill set in
practice
see a lot of people understand
meditation while it's
it gives you all the benefits we've
learned immediately drops your stress
levels
allows you to be in more allows you more
self-control in your life
allows you to access more positive
ranges of feelings
on a consistent basis in that way
meditation is kind of like
practice for real life in practicing
opening up your mind not letting
thoughts hit you
finding space paying attention to your
breath then in real life
that distance between stimulus and
response elongates
you find your breath you find your
intention you
find good feelings in that space
and now you respond as a more mindful
person reason number four it boosts your
awareness with john assaraf
what does your morning routine look like
now what what's
you know so today was a little bit
different except for one thing because i
drove from san diego to la to be with
you
but i wake up i pee i do my meditation
20 to 30 minutes
every morning i don't care where i am in
the world that's what these people want
during that time
i i do a variety of different
meditations so there's meditations that
i can do
where i'm just observing my thoughts now
a lot of people think well i'm not
supposed to have thoughts when you
meditate
says whom there's hundreds of different
ways
to practice awareness see meditation is
the art
of awareness awareness internally
awareness externally but also the
various millions of
layers that exist in the physical and
the non-physical world
so this morning i did a meditation with
some ocean
sounds and so it was about five o'clock
i woke up this morning
sat in my little sofa you know with my
feet propped up and did a
20-so minute meditation in the dark with
the ocean just
listening to the ocean just paying
attention and going into a trance-like
state
where after two or three minutes like i
disappeared like my body
was part of air and space so today was i
was using
sound to get into that trance-like state
other days i'll do a mantra whether it's
you know a lot of people know
transcendental meditation so it's the om
mantra so you just take a deep breath in
and then as you exhale
[Laughter]
and the question is why would you do
that and the answer is any time you can
give your brain
a rhythm it will entrain to that rhythm
that's
one anytime you could pay attention to
your breath
inhale and exhale you turn off the
parasympathetic nervous system
um you turn on the parasympathetic
nervous system which is your rest and
relaxation
and your calm state of flow versus your
sympathetic nervous system which is the
stress response system of adrenaline
norepinephrine cortisol etc so when you
get the serotonin and oxytocin and
dopamine going
and you're in that state of calmness uh
you're able to enter deeper
levels of consciousness and awareness so
you're able to observe
a thought you're able to hear your
heartbeat you're able to
sense different things that are giving
are being risen in your body through
thoughts that you're having so you can
actually start to see
when i have this thought here's the
sensation in my body
and you start to get so attuned to
what's happening what stimuli is
happening within you that's producing
these sensations
that cause you to either take action or
not retreat or move forward
you can start to get a feel for how the
mechanics work
so um so i'll do that sometimes i'll put
on uh some of the tibetan monks and
chant with them
uh so i use sound no sound i use
breathing i use open eye
close die five minutes ten minutes 30
minutes so i practice
the art of being in control of my breath
not breathing just being one with the
entire universe and feeling this
other than normal state of consciousness
that we're used to it's not sleep and
it's not
you know conscious awareness you're in
an altered state of awareness
and you can you can enter deeper and
deeper and deeper
layers of energy which everything is
made up anyway
everything's connected we have this
obviously our physical body
but the space between you and i right
now there's just
vibrating packets of energy right and so
you're able to
access different layers of all of the
intelligence and information
that already exists in the universe
versus the memories that we have in our
brains
and that's magical reason number five it
calms you down with the dalai lama
when we feel a certain sort of
irritation during that moment
if that person concentrate fully
on the breathing nothing else
and breathing one two
three like 5 10 15 20
when you start breathing mentally
irritated
but then after 20 30 sort of
breathing your mental state
will be a little different little more
calm
since we are dealing with emotions
so the best method to deal with that is
so called meditation not for next life
not for heaven but
this is for day-to-day's well-being
reason number six
it brings you joy with chase jarvis i
think tim ferriss and i who
tim is a lovely hymn we've been friends
for a long time um
first of all a it was i i remember
a couple of conversations about isn't
this edge this like at the at your core
you got a fire in your belly you're
driven
you mentioned sort of type a hard
charging whatever words that you would
associate that
you start to believe your own story
that that is what has created your
success
we don't stop or pause we're unwilling
to part with that
even long enough to see if that
narrative itself narrative
is true because if we stop that hard
charging type a
aggro you know undercurrent will we lose
a step
will we lose two steps will we fall from
the position that we've worked so hard
to get ourselves into
i remember um specifically exactly where
i sit and talking to tim and he was
feeding me this line i was like all
those things you said
i thought the exact and i can only say
what my truth is i can't say what your
truth is tim but
just give it a shot how about what if
you were able to think about that thing
that you thought was propelling you
is actually an anchor that is the thing
that is keeping you
down or small or um or
at some percentage of your potential
rather than their way around try and
tell yourself that narrative just long
enough
for you to take a break from your aggro
hard charging type a
life and you know there's any one of
these types of meditation i happen to
steal your tim
and and i i found transcendental
meditation tmtm.org
as one that was sticky for me
tim you know ended up gravitating to
that same thing and
when you are able to make that switch
you realize as i did i think as tim did
that and when you say switch i mean
switch in the narrative yeah switch the
narrative and
change your daily habits such that
meditation is a part of your day-to-day
for me it was quickly easy to see that
oh my god
this is actually it's like a rocket it's
like a booster
because now everything around me is
happening in slow motion i don't get
fired up and it was a fundamental change
in the way that i
sort of interacted with the world and i
don't it's like i don't want to
preach meditation because it's not for
everybody
if there is just if you read tools for
titans tim's book oh of course
the number one correlated thing across
all those people some sort of
mindfulness practice
now you ready yeah i'm going to be the
[ __ ] that says this for everybody
there you go because i'm just taking it
from a neurological perspective there
you go like
purely from a neurological perspective
because i know what's happening right
you're tapping into the parasympathetic
nervous system
you're calming down the sympathetic like
it's just it's uh
biochemistry right yeah so if you
believe in biochemistry then
give it a shot i'm a huge advocate i try
not to sell it too hard
because anytime someone's trying to tell
you something it feels you know feels
inauthentic but
it's just given me a lot of joy and
reason number seven the last one before
a very special bonus clip is
it makes you more effective with tim
ferriss
i get a lot of questions about how to
start meditating keeping in mind
that i had a very severe allergy to
the word and concept of meditation for a
very long time
more than a decade and i've only really
consistently
started meditating and uh
implemented meditating for the last two
to three years this is why i think
meditation
can be viewed in a way
as
stoic training or in some ways similar
to
cbt cognitive behavioral therapy because
the objective is to help you to
observe your state and your thoughts so
that you are less controlled by them
what does this mean i'll use an analogy
that
i think was originally shared with me by
andy puticombe
who is the founder of something called
headspace which i'll talk about in a
second
which is the difference in effect being
say
standing out in the storm getting pelted
with rain and hail and wind and stinging
your eyes and so on being soaking wet
or standing inside looking through the
glass
at the storm the latter is meditation
the way i've put it
before which is slightly different it's
the difference between being in the
washing machine
or standing outside looking into the
washing machine
and when you have that somewhat detached
observer perspective
you can just be much calmer much
more appreciative and ultimately
effective i do not think that meditation
causes you to lose your edge this was a
concern of mine and i think it's a
concern of a lot of type a
driven people but even if it did
cause you to lose say 10 who cares
ultimately you're trying to succeed and
make more money do all these things
build a bigger business
to improve the quality of life for
yourself or others and you achieve that
i think more directly
in many cases by even if you had to take
say a 10
haircut on your edge by improving your
present state awareness
by uh much much more 50 to 100
so let's jump into a couple of options
right so if you're not a dog
because dogs are always present stay
aware
then you need some human tools one
option and this is the way i
started very early on meditating was
listening to one song so
find one song that puts you into a good
mood and in the morning
all you're going to do is sit
comfortably so this could be sitting in
a chair
feet on the floor just like this
hands in your lap uh you generally are
going to want some some type of back
support
uh you do not need a dog chewing on a
squeaky toy
um so i may intervene molly come here
oh or you can sit like this
which is uh how i tend to sit when i
meditate
so this is not full lotus this is half
lotus it's not even half lotus it's
really just one foot tucked into the
crease
of my calf and thigh and then i'm going
to kind of
pull the butt cheeks so that i have a
nice little seat
here back flat and then my hands are
either going to be
in my lap like so or i will actually
post my hands on my thighs
like this which can also help if you
have a tendency of slouching
to keep your back straight all right
listen to one song
for me it was uh we're gonna party like
it's 1999 prince
it's hard to be uh stressed out worrying
about things if you listen to that song
trust me
you can pick whatever poison you like
but this was shared with me by kamal
robicon
and he suggested listening to one song
doing nothing in particular other than
listening to the song and breathing and
that's three to four minutes that's it
so you could try that in the morning
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated but never created a plan
and when you share your plan and have
accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
i never thought i'd do this meditation
creates a natural environment for the
body to heal itself
michael edwards michael said i needed to
do healing meditation
now i fully believe in the benefits of
meditation i believe the science
i believe the people who tell me it
works for them but it never worked for
me
i've tried following youtube videos
guided meditation apps and
one-on-one coaching with some of the
best meditation teachers
in the world but i never felt anything i
didn't feel any different coming out of
a meditation than going in i must have
tried 30 to 40 different techniques
from different people because i believe
that it works
i just never found the method that
worked for me and yet
the thing that never worked for me was
the very thing my new advisor promised
would heal my broken neck
great i'm all in tell me what to do he
gave me specific music to listen to
specific visualizations to do while
meditating specific instructions
on how to position myself specific
instructions on timing and frequency he
followed up with me regularly and kept
sending his support
belief and guidance when i loaded my
messages his was the first one i went to
because at this moment in my life he was
one of the most important people around
me
i did the meditations because i believed
in michael and i believed in michael
because he told his story
again it comes back to his story his
journey got my attention
it got me to do something that i had
never had success with
i stuck with it i did a morning and
evening meditation
every day exactly like michael had
instructed me to do i didn't miss a
single day
what was a nice to have luxury suddenly
became a top priority
because i needed to get rid of this
concussion from my broken neck
then i started to heal within a couple
days i started feeling better
i still had a lot of brain fog but i
could start to think again one week
later i was able to lead a workshop for
an hour and a half
another week later i could lead my full
three hour workshop two more weeks and i
stopped getting dizzy when i lay down
the broken bone in my neck also healed
was it because of my meditation
or just no more healing i honestly don't
know but i was dedicated to my
meditation because i wanted to heal like
michael had
he told his story and it impacted me now
it's time for you
to tell yours
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me and if you want the dalai lama's top
10 rules to success check the video
right there next to me continue to
believe
and i'll see you there